was one of the best nights of my life
maybe the best night of my career every
comic talks about theaters and then they
talk about the Wilbur it's the best
theater for stand-up yeah it's awesome
in my opinion everybody says that it was
all my dreams like I'd see so and so at
the Wilbur and I was like yo I gotta do
the Wilbur and this is my first time
headlining Boston ever I [__] love
this song
I thought we were gonna wrap the tour up
with New York at Caroline's and I just
hadn't hit Boston there's a few cities I
just didn't hit we kept getting emails
saying come to Boston come to Boston my
agent was like do you want to just try
the Wilbur and I was like yeah let's go
for it and see what happens so now we've
sold it out and I don't have to stress
about it I only need to worry about the
intro not [__] that up and I need to
worry about my jokes and making sure the
audience likes the show and that's it
and that's a huge relief we're trying to
get a fire intro we got some dancers
coming I'm very nervous about dancing
because I'm 38 and fatter than I was
before I got married so I'm hoping the
moves are simple and if I [__] up those
moves that's a bad foot to start off on
literally we're heading to the Wilbur
I'm gonna work on this entrance get this
[__] fired lock it in and then hopefully
I don't [__] up my jokes and ruin the
whole show 54 degrees I'm entirely
overdressed and I'm not gonna take off
anything
I look like an idiot I look like a real
herb
s
yeah I've dreamed of doing this theater
I just want to see what it looks like
what we're doing you know I used to hear
people doing the Wilbur yeah dude I
cannot wait to [__] do the wheel but
they're gonna sell this one out
cool that's fair I love it but I
couldn't have done so that you can't I
couldn't have done this without you
great you just got here yeah I did all
this without you
are you dancing
a move I could do without
yes
that's that that's it that's it I'll
give you something a little more
complicated yeah I mean I'm not white
running back one time uh go all out this
time save your knees and [__] though
roll fire
yeah I got chills guys that was amazing
you guys ready for your headliner
ah the Wilbur is like one of my dream
venues including Arenas come on boss I
know we could do a little better better
than that by all accounts may be the
best venue in the world for time from
the flagrant podcast put your heads
together sake
[Applause]
[Music]
wow yes
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up
clubs
[Music]
thank you guys so much get home safe go
have a good night thank you
is it possible to get another one of
those cookies or maybe two the cookie
with the iceberg
yes I don't think so because they shut
down the kitchen no
that's phenomenal back there whatever
they're doing is Magic that's the best
part